France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe nous vous proposons
cette semaine une émission entière
consacrée à l'aide que l'Union
européenne fournit aux régions au grand
projet aux citoyens européens à travers
ces subventions et ses plans de relance
nous avons naturellement invité pour en
parler la commissaire européenne en
charge de la cohésion et des réformes
Elisa Ferreira bonjour nous sommes
depuis les studios de la commission ici
à Bruxelles nous rappelons votre
parcours économiste professeur
d'ailleurs d'économie ancienne ministre
de l'Environnement de la planification
de gouvernement portugais successifs
socialiste ancienne vice gouverneur de
la Banque du Portugal est député
européenne pendant 12 ans alors
aujourd'hui effectivement vous êtes à la
tête d'un budget conséquent tout de même
si on compte annuellement c'est 48
milliards d'euros à peu près sur 189
milliards d'euros de budget total c'est
donc le deuxième poste de dépenses après
la politique agricole commune suffisant
vraiment pour faire face à de multiples
crises c'est difficile de répondre
positivement parce que vraiment les
mêmes si la politique de cohésion a
contribué d'une façon très très
déterminante pour la
convergence européenne on peut rappeler
que les pays qui ont qui ont été membres
de la l'Union européenne un peu plus
tard
en 2004 2016
ils avaient une richesse par habitant de
la moitié de l'Union européenne un peu
plus que la moitié maintenant ils ont
trois quarts et
kalks parmi eux ont déjà atteint
80% de la moyenne européenne alors la
politique de cohésion est assez forte
mais en tout cas on a été forcé aussi à
faire des politiques d'émergence à
changer et adapter la politique et je
suis fière je peux le dire
euh que en fait la première aide pour
éviter une crise énorme avec le problème
du covid a été vraiment
apporter par la politique de cohésion
après pour les réfugiés qui sont venus
de crème quand la Russie a envahi
l'Ukraine c'était de nouveau la
politique de cohésion alors les
sollicitations elles sont énormes mais
en tout cas il y a beaucoup de travail
une bonne nouvelle pour les Français
dans ce que vient de décider la
Commission européenne relativement au
financement par cette politique de
cohésion des grandes entreprises
expliquez-nous oui c'est quelque chose
sur laquelle les Français étaient
présentement
et en fait pour la première fois pour
les secteurs stratégiques européens et
ça veut dire la technologie profonde ça
veut dire
la biotechnologie ça veut dire les ind
de l'environnement on verra si les chefs
d'État et du Gouvernement et le
Parlement européen sont d'accord mais on
a proposé que les régions les plus
pauvres des pays qui sont assez riches
la France est un pays assez riche mais
en tout cas puisse utiliser les fonds
culturelles si elles veulent exactement
pour financer comme si elles avaient la
capacité de faire des aides États dans
les limites des états aussi
financiers
et ça et ça concerne toutes les régions
françaises à l'exception de la région
parisienne et Auvergne Rhône-Alpes la
commission effective a proposé
d'affecter ce budget à ce budget les
recettes de la nouvelle taxe carbone aux
frontières une partie des recettes de du
marché carbone et une ponction sur la
taxation des bénéfices des entreprises
est-ce que vous avez besoin de nouvelles
ressources justement est-ce que le
budget en tant que tel il est suffisant
ça c'est évident c'est évident c'est
très difficile quand on quand on pense
tout ce que la Commission européenne et
l'Europe fait et a fait même pendant la
crise mais de faire d'ailleurs nouveau
en permanence depuis tout à tout ce qui
se passe ce sont les migrants sont les
régions des peuplées sont les régions ou
très périphériques sont celles de
développement c'est l'agriculture tout
ça on le fait avec un budget qui est à
peu près 1% 1% du pays
de l'Union européenne que l'Union
européenne a commencé à être a été
établi il y avait des recettes
douanières de la de toutes les
importations alors avec le temps et les
négociations internationales tout ça est
disparu même les prélèvements sur le
sucre surtout beaucoup d'importations
alors il faut qu'on cherche d'autres
sources pour renforcer le budget
européen et surtout maintenant qu'on a
toute cette incertitude par exemple avec
la guerre alors pour en savoir plus sur
votre politique de cohésion Elisa
Ferreira je vous propose des exemples de
son application elle a pour but de
rééquilibrer en l'expliquer les régions
européennes entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres comme nous l'explique tout
de suite Sophie samay
[Musique]
la politique de cohésion ne
profite-t-elle jamais au pays les plus
riches la politique de cohésion est
financée par les États membres qui
versent leur code par au budget européen
chacun contribue plus ou moins selon la
taille de son économie et tous reçoivent
en retour des subventions en fonction de
leurs besoins point retour sur
investissement différencier
[Musique]
les pays appelés contributeurs nets
donnent effectivement plus qu'il ne
reçoivent en retour pour leur région en
difficulté pour la période 2021 2027 ils
sont au nombre de neufs l'Allemagne la
France l'Italie les Pays-Bas l'Autriche
la Finlande la Suède le Danemark et
l'Irlande
ensemble il réhausse le niveau des pays
aux régions les plus en difficulté les
bénéficiaires net comme la Pologne la
Grèce la Hongrie ou la Roumanie
mais cet apport conséquent leur confère
aussi des avantages non négligeables
outre la stabilité politique que cette
solidarité financière soutient le
développement économique d'un État
membre à généralement des effets
bénéfiques chez ses voisins grâce au
marché unique européen par exemple la
première ligne de train à grande vitesse
des pays baltes financés en partie par
les fonds structurelles sera conçue par
des entreprises espagnoles françaises et
allemandes autre exemple les universités
roumaines aidé par le FEDER et le FSE
plus forme chaque année des milliers
d'étudiants français qui reviennent
ensuite exercés dans l'Hexagone l'idée
qu'il y aurait donc déperdants et des
gagnants du budget de la politique de
cohésion et caricaturale et donc plutôt
fausse
[Musique]
voilà parce que vous savez que ça
revient on n'est pas presque à un an de
des élections européennes ça revient
tout le temps sur la table notamment en
France nous sommes et puis dans 10 pays
on l'a dit nous sommes contributeurs net
au budget de l'Union européenne les
parties les plus populistes mettent se
fait en avant pour vouloir justement
moins d'Europe mais la France elle
reçoit beaucoup de la politique agricole
commune de la cohésion aussi y compris
les régions et c'est d'ailleurs les
régions qui vous remercient Madame la
Commissaire à la cohésion parce que d'un
certain point de vue peut-être qu'elles
auraient été un peu plus oubliées au
National vous croyez pas oui les régions
les plus pauvres bien sûr
la question que vous que vous posez
c'est une question très très
essentiel et fondamentale toutes les
régions reçoivent de l'argent de la
politique de cohésion le type de projet
qu'on appuie dans une région comme
Île-de-France n'est pas la même chose
qu'on fait de même type d'appui qu'on
veut faire dans une région
Martinique ou Guadeloupe ce qui est
important c'est ne pas aller dans un
débat sur qui paye et qui reçoit dans un
montant qui est 1% de la richesse parce
que
l'argenta qui contribue vraiment pour la
richesse sont les investissements
croisés il marchait unique quand j'ai
des ministres de l'Environnement une
grande partie des investissements par
exemple dans les réseaux
d'assainissement basique et d'eau était
des contrats avec des entreprises
françaises et très bien parce qu'elles
étaient fortes il y a toujours sur
investissement d'ailleurs dans dans
effectivement le privé c'est que de tout
l'argent qui est envoyé à la Pologne ou
à la
Bulgarie ou à la Roumanie elle retourne
vraiment sur les pays qui s'appelle
à eux-mêmes contributeur mais la
conséquence c'est qu'on a une croissance
cette croissance apporte des
investissements et leurs investissements
sont ouverts dans un marché unique
ouvert vraiment pour les entreprises des
pays contributeurs alors c'est vrai que
ça a marché d'ailleurs c'est 20 c'est 10
dernières années la politique de la
cohésion dans le rééquilibrage régional
ça vous l'avez bien expliqué mais par
contre il y a une étude qui a été menée
par des chercheurs de l'Université de
Mannheim du centre Jacques Delord de
Berlin qui qui disent que finalement ça
n'est pas aller suffisamment par contre
au lycée pour compte c'est-à-dire les
plus pauvres des plus pauvres dans ces
régions et qui allaient peut-être
réformer de façon plus radicale cette
politique de cohésion qui est sur des
bases territoriales et régionales pour
essayer d'aller toucher finalement les
plus vulnérables par niveau de revenus
est-ce que c'est vrai j'ai des doutes
sur le la conclusion de cette étude oui
c'est vrai qu'il y a encore des régions
qui sont très très pauvres et je
dans la situation française par exemple
Mayotte est une région qui est encore
très très pauvre la plupart des régions
polonaises au bulgare romaine elles ont
une situation encore faible mais le taux
de croissance qu'on enregistre dans des
depuis l'adhésion elle est vraiment
remarquable quelquefois c'est au niveau
de la structure de gestion de la
capacité de ces régions ou de des
gouvernements locaux de s'organiser pour
utiliser les disponibilités des fonds en
tout cas ça nous préoccupe on travaille
sur ça si vous regardez la plupart des
pays dès qu'il
rejoignent l'Union européenne le taux de
croissance immédiatement il est
complètement changé dans le sens positif
mais les inégalités entre les citoyens
tiennent il y a encore des inégalités si
vous prenez des inégalités entre pays ça
y est vraiment très très réduit si vous
regardez les inégalités à l'intérieur
des pays ou même à l'intérieur d'une
ville comme comme Paris qui est une des
plus riches de l'Europe il y a des
inégalités mais il faut aussi que
l'entité qui est responsable soit le
pays soit la région soit la municipalité
n'importe où s'il y a des inégalités
aussi que ça devient une priorité de la
politique et pas quelque chose qu'on
écarte et c'est l'Union européenne qui
doit le faire on peut couper ses fonds
de cohésion s'il y a mauvais respect de
l'État de droit de la cour du Luxembourg
a d'ailleurs donné raison à la
Commission européenne contre la Pologne
le Parti conservateur nationaliste droit
et justice au pouvoir avaient engagé un
bras de fer depuis 2021 et avait refusé
de se conformer aux recommandations sur
sa réforme judiciaire
liberticide par votre commission la
Pologne refusait de payer son allemand
l'exécutif a décidé que elle allait le
payer qu'on allait le prélever sur vos
fonds de cohésion pour 2021 2027 360
millions d'euros ça veut dire quoi pour
la Pologne maintenant que c'est décidé
il y a une demande respect par la Charte
la charte fondamentale de droits
d'hommes et ça inclut bien sûr le
respect pour la diversité soit diversité
de genre médias d'autres demandes comme
un système de justice qui peut être
vraiment
efficace et qui peut comme vous le savez
c'est la première instance d'appel alors
s'il y a un conflit un terme par exemple
gestion de fonds structurelle il faut
qu'il a la garantie d'une indépendance
judicielle alors la carte des droits
fondamentaux doit être respecté par tous
les pays ça fait partie de l'accès aux
principes du club il y a encore des
problèmes à résoudre dans dans le cas de
la Pologne on est en dialogue permanent
avec avec la Pologne et on attend
vraiment du procréas votre argent de la
cohésion vous avez commencé à dire
l'argent
même mais l'argent de la cohésion elle
était attribué en effet pour partir au
réfugiés
ukrainien pour parer à l'urgence est-ce
que ça n'est pas en train de devenir
justement un grand portefeuille de
l'urgence et on est en train de piocher
dedans et ce qu'il ne risque pas de se
déliter justement ce portefeuille c'est
de nouveau une bonne question
une question qui est qui est très très
visible
personnellement je suis fière de ce
qu'on a fait parce qu'avait la vérité
était que soit pour la crise covid soit
pour les réfugiés et après avec la
hausse des prix de l'énergie
si on n'aurait pas
introduit des changements qui d'ailleurs
ont mérité l'approbation je crois
presque unanime ou une anime du
Parlement européen et du Conseil
beaucoup de pays et vraiment beaucoup de
régions
aurait eu une chute majeure de sa de son
économie et même en termes sociales ça
serait vraiment dramatique
Ferreira l'offensive a commencé côté
ukrainien est-ce qu'on est optimiste au
sein du collège des commissaires sur
l'avenir sur la possibilité d'ailleurs
des Ukrainiens à regagné du terrain sur
les Russes ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il y a une conviction énorme
que l'Europe doit appuyer l'Union
européenne doit appuyer et on le fait en
permanence appuyer les ukrainiens et
aura fait en relation au réfugiés et on
continue à faire tout l'appui qu'on peut
et même on a on a pris la décision
récemment de proposer aux conseils aux
chefs d'État et de gouvernement et au
Parlement européen un appui de 50
milliards pour la reconstruction c'est
une obligation aussi morale de tous les
Européens et si je si vous me permettez
je vous remercier publiquement les
Français et tous les Européens je le
fais très souvent de l'accueil
incroyable qu'ils ont qu'ils ont donné à
des gens qui avaient tout perdu leur
existence était coupée d'un jour à
l'autre alors on a créé tous les
instruments de flexibilité si je ajoute
tout ce qu'on a dépensé des fonds
investis des fonds structurer à la dans
ces situations d'urgence ça serait à peu
près 10% de du budget global plus réel
qui est comme vous l'avez reconnu un
budget assez fort et alors je crois que
c'est de l'argent très bien utilisé
parce que autrement la situation
économique et politique de l'Europe ne
serait pas la même je crois MERCI Elisa
Ferrera en tout cas commissaire au
réformes et à la cohésion d'avoir été
notre invité aujourd'hui merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis on continue sur le
thème des plans de relance avec notre
grand débat en compagnie d'euros députés
et de Public Sénat c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Bruxelles pour
parler grossou historique en 2020 face à
la pandémie l'Union européenne décidait
d'un plan de relance intitulé next
generation
u au total 724 milliards d'euros ont été
levés sur les marchés par une dette en
commun pour pouvoir en bénéficier chacun
des 27 a dû faire valider un plan
national d'investissement dans la
transition climatique et numérique alors
que 150 milliards d'euros ont déjà été
versés aux États membres par la
Commission européenne la question de
leur emploi se pose tout comme celle du
contrôle et de la transparence oui parce
que c'est pour mieux encadrer ses prêts
et subventions chaque État membre de
l'Union européenne devra désormais
rendre public la liste descend plus
importants bénéficiaires le Parlement
européen vient de voter cette obligation
à la mi-février des aides européennes
aussi conditionnées à une bonne gestion
nationale garantie par des réformes
structurelles mais aussi au bon respect
de l'État de droit et d'ailleurs c'est
fond ont été gelés dans certains pays
comme la Hongrie ou la Pologne Bruxelles
tente de contrôler la bonne utilisation
de cet argent pour donner des gages au
contribuables européens qui
rembourseront cette dette jusqu'en 2058
c'est vraiment les projets financés par
ce plan de relance exceptionnel y a-t-il
un contrôle effectif et bien pour en
débattre 2 euros députés à une minute à
bonjour vous êtes du groupe Renou vous
êtes roumain la Roumanie qui est
d'ailleurs en attente d'un prochain
versement bienvenue à vous et puis face
à vous Nora et barrek socialiste
français la France a touché une première
tronche en dessus de 12 milliards et
demi après la validation de son plan sur
les 40 milliards prévus est-ce que cet
argent européen il était nécessaire pour
un pays aussi riche que la France oui
parce que cet argent européen était
nécessaire pour les 27 États membres
finalement qu'il soit plus riches ou
moins parce qu'on sortait d'un temps où
on avait eu un blocage mondial de
l'activité économique de l'activité tout
court finalement qu'on a appelé le
confinement sortait de d'une crise qui
pour l'Union européenne a été le moyen
en tout cas sur pour le Parlement comme
pour la commission d'être créatif et
vous l'avez dit en début de propos ce
plan de relance et ce plan finalement de
contribution de solidarité commune donne
un sens à aussi à l'Union européenne et
donc il était important que la France
comme d'autres les amandes puissent en
bénéficier vous l'avez dit 40 milliards
d'euros je cite un exemple 40 milliards
d'euros c'est aussi pour la France la
particularité d'accompagner le plan de
transition énergétique a été annoncé par
le gouvernement il y a pas très
longtemps un exemple concret quand on
fait de la rénovation des bâtiments
publics qu'ils soient d'ailleurs pour
les particuliers comme pour les
établissements à la fois entreprise et
public et bien c'est du plan de relance
européen et donc oui pour aussi répondre
à ce défi qui est devant nous à savoir
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ce plan de relance était
important alors c'est vrai que Monsieur
mitouta votre pays la Roumanie c'est un
pays des plus des plus pauvres de
l'Union européenne qui reçoit déjà
beaucoup d'autres font structurels
justement pour son rattrapage est-ce que
véritablement ce plan de relance
européen il est indispensable pour vous
et ce que vous pouvez nous citer des
exemples concrets de ce que ça change
finalement poste pandémie et en pleine
guerre en Ukraine
donc il faut comprendre que le plan de
relance est très important pour tous les
pays y compris pour mon pays pour la
Roumanie mais il faut aussi ne pas
oublier qu'on a aussi accès à la au fond
des cohésions au fond de cohésion la
Roumanie a accès à des fonds de 50
milliards d'euros pour les prochains 7
ans c'est en somme c'est une somme qui
est très grande qui nous aide vraiment
en fait
les réformes qu'on a besoin et je pense
que pour le plan de relance le plus
essentiel c'est pas seulement le montant
c'est pas seulement les milliards
d'euros qui vont couler dans le pays
mais c'est aussi le réformes parce que
pour avoir accès au fond il faut aussi
mettre en place des réformes et surtout
la réforme qui sont liées à la
transition écologique et la transition
digitale je pense que on essaie de
pousser du niveau européen tous les pays
européens de faire de pas de faire des
pas en avant sur ces transformations qui
sont des transformations européennes
dont on a besoin vraiment le plus grand
projet qui est financé par la par le
plan de relan c'est une autoroute qui
lie de région historique de Roumanie la
Moldavie et le la le sud de la Roumanie
il y avait un problème qui date depuis
longtemps donc on n'a pas une connexion
par autoroute entre ces deux régions
historiques de la Roumanie et à travers
l'autoroute c'est pas très belle mais on
est on va essayer de faire une autoroute
qui est plus belle que les autres ça
veut dire qu'on va aussi mettre des par
exemple des bonnes recharge pour les
voitures électriques des choses comme ça
pour le faire plus écologique disons de
plus en plus ONG d'associations de
parlementaires dénonce le manque de
transparence autour de l'utilisation de
ces fonds on a demandé d'ailleurs à
afficher les 100 premiers bénéficiaires
le Parlement l'a demandé expressément
comme toute bonne utilisation de fonds
publics il est important pour chacun de
citoyens européens de savoir où est-ce
que l'argent a été mis et notamment au
niveau national d'autant que sur les
plans de relance là où on est nous la
commission finalement membre de la
Commission de la cohésion qui est le
premier budget européen parce que la
cohésion pour nous est un élément
essentiel du projet de solidarité
européenne qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en
terme de concertation on a toujours
travaillé les programmations des fonds
européens avec les collectivités
territoriales parce que l'échelons
locales est un échelon qui est pertinent
pour pouvoir répondre aux défis à la
fois d'engagement sur le contre le
réchauffement climatique et la
neutralité carbone mais aussi en termes
de transport en terme de développement
économique en termes de formation ce qui
a manqué en termes de conditionnalité si
je puis mettre les deux au même niveau
ce qui est de critères c'est la
co-construction avec les territoires on
a eu un plan de relance qui finalement a
accompagner la relance du PIB et de la
nationale
et qui alors que précisé et d'ailleurs
l'État est contrôleur ce qui est un
problème et on a eu le sentiment enfin
pas le sentiment on dénonce ce
d'ailleurs que une régression sur la
relationnalisation de certaines
politiques européennes et notamment de
fond de cohésion qui jusque là était la
démonstration de l'utilité de l'Union
européenne au plus près des territoires
qu'ils soient ruraux ou métropolitain je
cite un exemple si la France décide je
n'ai pas dit que c'était le cas mais sur
les 46% alloués du plan de relance que
la France a décidé de la louer à la
transition énergétique si elle décide de
tout mettre sur l'île de France
et de ne pas prendre
et aucune possibilité pour les régions
et pour l'Union européenne d'agir pour
qu'il y ait une répartition équitable et
ça c'est le grand regret de relance et
qui nécessite du coup le fait qu'on ait
voté une demande de transparence et
parce que manque de concertation est
égal du coup à opacité sur les projets
choisis je vois que vous êtes d'accord
Monsieur misouta je voudrais qu'on
revienne je suis tout à fait d'accord en
fait on a besoin non seulement de la
transparence mais on a besoin du
contrôle de fond et c'est pour ça par
exemple qu'on a une nouvelle institution
le parquet européenne qui a fait déjà
des des avancements assez importants
dans ce domaine je pense que seulement
en 2022 ils ont gelé des milliers des
centaines de millions de d'euros y
compris des fonds de du plan de relance
et de des fonds de cohésion donc il est
important de garder d'une part une
transparence 100% au niveau des fonds
des public mais aussi de contrôler le le
la dépense des fonds européennes et
c'est pour ça qu'on a cette institution
le paquet européen qui est vraiment très
efficace justement vous parliez de
conditionnalités on va partir tout de
suite en direction de la Hongrie parce
que face à de nombreuses atteintes à
l'indépendance de la justice et au
plaisir pluralisme médiatique dans ce
pays la Commission a gelée en fait en
décembre dernier 22 milliards d'euros
prévus pour la Hongrie dans le budget de
l'Union européenne budget plus réelle
mais aussi là Hongrie essaye
désespérément de débloquer les 5,8
milliards d'euros de subventions du plan
de relance post covid l'argent est-il
bien investi en Hongrie le reportage
tout de suite de notre envoyé spécial
là-bas Luc proud la ligne 3 du métro de
Budapest un demi-million d'usagers
l'empreinte chaque jour c'est la plus
fréquentée de la capitale hongroise
depuis 2016 elle a fait peau neuve grâce
notamment à des fonds européens de 418
millions d'euros pour des nouveaux
ascenseurs et des accès handicapés
améliorés des subventions des pensées en
conformité avec les objectifs de la
politique de cohésion mais en gris ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas à gauche à
d'Asie traque la corruption direction le
village natal de Victor Hormann ces 10
dernières années l'argent de l'UE a
financé cette sculpture monumentale à la
carte artificielle où ce train
touristique quasiment inexploité
c'est le premier exemple bien connu ce
petit train qui va de nulle part à nulle
part 5 km et deux arrêts c'est un
investissement de 2 millions d'euros ce
n'est pas forcément beaucoup mais c'est
un exemple parfait pour constater un
investissement sans utilité dans un pays
avec de l'argent européen et tout cela à
la demande de Victor Hormann
la Hongrie fait partie des cinq derniers
pays de l'Union qui ont refusé de
rejoindre le parquet européen une
instance qui permet notamment d'enquêter
sur les fraudes potentiels liés à
l'utilisation des fonds structurels sous
pression de la Commission européenne
Budapest a proposé 17 mesures
correctives dont une nouvelle autorité
de l'intégrité pour surveiller appel
d'offres et patrimoine d'élus
inefficace pour cette ONG face au 50000
cas de corruption suspectées
sur les institutions existantes pour ces
enquêtes et ne peut pas se tourner vers
le tribunal lui-même pour l'instruction
d'une affaire
en plus elle est dépendante du ministère
public qui a été critiquée à plusieurs
reprises pour ne pas avoir enquêté
correctement et refuser d'instruire des
poursuites à haut niveau
en plus des fonds structurels
habituelles Bruxelles retient 5,8
milliards de subventions et 6,6 de près
dans le cadre du plan de relance
hongrois
la commission réclame à Budapest 27
super mesures pour mettre fin à la main
mise du pouvoir sur le judiciaire au
détournement de fonds européens et
garantir la transparence
et aboutissent à un mauvais effet usage
des subventions le chantage à l'argent
exercé par l'Union européenne dans le
cadre du plan de relance notamment pour
obliger les pays à revenir à de bonnes
pratiques démocratiques ça marche avec
Victor Hormann je pense que ça va
marcher parce que Victor hugmann et
peut-être très conscient qu'il prive
les Hongrois d'investissement pour faire
face aux défis qui sont aujourd'hui
devant la Hongrie et devant l'Union
européenne 2 des fonds ailleurs oui bien
sûr mais enfin on rappelle juste que
entre le moment où le plan de relance
est négocié pour l'ensemble des États
membres et aujourd'hui on a une guerre
aux portes de l'Union européenne et que
on est les premiers évidemment à vouloir
que le respect des tas de droit soit
le chapeau est-ce que c'est juste
finalement de lier cet État de droit au
versement des plans de relance est-ce
que finalement les pays qui ont des
dérivés pratiques n'ont pas été aussi
touchés par le covid qui ont besoin de
se rebooster ce que vous trouvez que
finalement c'est le discours de Victor
hormone il dit ça doit être indépendant
ça ne doit pas être lié est-ce que cette
conditionnalité elle est justifiée selon
vous
je pense que c'est la conditionnalité
est tout à fait justifiée les fonds
publics et les fonds européens ne sont
pas en distributeurs de billets parce
que on parle de contribution de nos
soutien citoyens donc pour cette raison
je pense que l'Union européenne doit
vraiment
contrôler très bien les comment les
fonctions dépensés je pense que la
conditionnalité est un instrument qui
est vraiment essentiel pour nous au
Parlement européen nous on a toujours
dit je pense que c'est presque
uneanimité au Parlement européenne de
dire que la Hongrie ou la Pologne parce
qu'il y a aussi des problèmes en Pologne
devaient avoir accès au fond en public
soit les fonds de cohésion soit les
fonds de relance seulement si l'ampleur
mise en place
tout ce qui est lié au l'État à l'état
de droit mais aussi les réformes
des réformes structurelles en Belgique
le prochain versement est conditionné à
la réforme des retraites l'Italie
Giorgia Meloni elle a déjà reçu 42 le
versement d'une troisième tranche de 19
milliards d'euros a été gelé par la
Commission en attendant des
clarifications sur l'affectation des
fonds et des retards dans les réformes
est-ce que c'est le rôle de la
Commission de s'immiscer dans les
politiques budgétaires de l'État de
réclamer une réforme des retraites ça
n'a pas été le cas en France mais
finalement ça aurait pu parce que là
vous trouvez que c'est le rôle également
de l'Union européenne alors d'abord je
rappelle juste que sur l'état de
conditionnalités notamment sur le
respect de l'État de droit dont on a
parlé à la fois pour la Hongrie comme
pour la polyOne je vous rappelle qu'il
voulait geler des zones LGBT interdire
des gens être dans un espace commun je
rappelle que c'est juste les traités
européens qui donc la commission c'est
voilà la commission c'est juste
contenter finalement par rappel et par
obligation du Parlement à faire
respecter puisqu'elle est garante des
traités à faire respecter les traités ça
c'est une chose exige une réforme des
retraites exiger la réforme des
retraites en fait moi je pense que
historiquement ce qui est historique
dans le cadre du plan de relance c'est
qu'on a fait péter le dogme les 3% de
déficit c'est ça qui s'est passé que la
Commission a accepté ainsi que le
conseil de sortir donc en échange on
demande des ressorts et du coup moi je
pense qu'en échange on devrait pas
demander ça on devrait demander un
projet qui soit sur un projet politique
qui voit vers le progrès et que toute la
question qui se pose c'est la
construction du budget européen et
pourquoi on milite pour qu'il y ait un
budget avec des ressources propres c'est
pour éviter que les conditionnalités
soient mises sur une réforme qui impacte
directement les les citoyens à savoir
qu'il fasse régresser les droits sociaux
c'est toute une question de projet vous
êtes pour la conditionnalité Hongrie en
Pologne mais pas en Belgique je suis en
conditionnel je suis pour la
conditionnalité à partir du moment où
elle bafoue à l'état de droit je ne suis
pas pour de la conditionnalité qui
empêcherait le progrès des Européens
donc c'est une question de vision et de
projet de confrontation de projet
politique qui sera du coup à l'orée de
la préparation budgétaire un élément
important pour le Parlement mais
justement il y a un côté inédit
finalement dans cette ce grand plan de
relance plus de 700 milliards d'euros
une dette en commun qui a été faite et
soyons peut-être clair par rapport à nos
téléspectateurs sans cet argent est-ce
que on se porterait aussi bien
aujourd'hui les différents pays
je pense que sans cet argent
il y a beaucoup de difficultés de de
sortir de la crise énergétique par
exemple de la crise énergétique mais de
la crise de la de la pandémie parce
qu'on a vu pour deux années ou même plus
nos économies ont beaucoup souffert et
donc pour cela on a besoin de deux
investissements qui sont qui devaient
être des investissements du niveau
européen parce que on est lié donc
l'économie européenne est liée on parle
pas de l'économie française roumaine
grecs ou ainsi de suite donc il faut
vraiment avoir une vision européenne sur
la direction où on veut aller c'est pour
ça que je dis que pas seulement le fait
qu'on ne sort d'une crise énergétique de
la pandémie mais le il y a aussi le fait
que on doit on a une direction positive
où on veut aller ça veut dire la
transformation digitale la
transformation écologique ça ça
a besoin aussi de d'une approche
européenne c'est pour ça que je pense ce
plan de relance à une double
double ça veut dire on sort d'une crise
mais aussi on avance sur un certain
chemin qui est le chemin de la
transformation et on se projette dans
l'avenir merci merci à tous les deux
d'avoir débattu sur notre plateau merci
à vous bien sûr de nous avoir suivis
vous restez sur nos deux antennes pour
plus d'informations
[Musique]